here they are the latest calls between
former President Obama and President
Trump no one celebrates Black History
Month we just honor and remember great
african-american Oh what's wrong well I
just sent you a big ice cream cake
that's made black about Rushmore Jesus
Donna losing the cake em okay Frederick
Douglass yeah I went with for Shaquille
oh dude yeah I'm on vacation do a
20-minute vacation from signing
executive orders not really a vacation
then why am I in the Oval of is wearing
nothing but flip-flops and a speedo I
don't want to imagine this you don't
have to I just texted you a picture
please don't
oh god I know I should have brushed my
leg hey bear why they calling Steve
banning the man behind the curtain
well because there's a shadowy
seldom-seen figure believed to be
driving a lot of decisions and holding a
lot of power oh well that's that's true
at all
it's not Steve said I have to go hello
it's me again I'm fired this week did
you hear how I told mexico's president
if we can't get his bed I'm brave under
control we'll send in troops to clean up
the mess
I sell pretty tough talk for a guy who's
scared of stairs Oh Chelsea yeah I dare
you to say that to my face
no problem why don't you meet me at the
top of the Statue of Liberty
[Applause]
you